Okay.
I wanna be very respectful of that if there is.
So, last week we talked about a really important part
of this, uh, growing towards deeper
intimacy in our relationships as couples,
and even with our kids and others.
Uh, being able to really, uh, communicate heart to heart
and keep a safe place for people to do that with us,
where they don't feel worried about how will you react
if I tell you I feel inadequate,
or, uh, anything like that.
We, we learned how to really tune in and,
and help people feel good and safe about that.
Um, but we were, we did not reserve enough time
to let you do the experiential, the exercise
that is actually part of that lesson.
And so, I, I'm gonna let you have a few moments to do
that tonight as we, pretty much, as we get started.
I'm gonna show a video first of Dr. Ferguson, um,
which is more about our experiencing a
deeper love with the Lord.
And I love some of these meditations that he does,
and, uh, just think it'll be a great way,
almost like praying a little longer.
But, um, what he's talking about in here is
a promise that can be seen in scripture of
how the Lord will pursue you with his love.
Mm-Hmm. Even if you're not pursuing
him, he's pursuing you.
And there've been many times when I've
needed him to pursue me.
So, uh, he's gonna reference John nine
and one that I mentioned last week is, uh,
the familiar passage, Psalm 23.
And in verse six, it says, he will follow you all the days
of your life with his mercy and his love.
He's following you. Now, sometimes I have
to slow down enough to let him catch me.
Does that make sense? I'm off doing my own thing,
but he's following us and pursuing us with his life.
So let's just, uh, have a listen here with, uh, David
and, uh, this,
all these clips are no more than four minutes.
Most of them are about three.
In the gospels is the man born blind.
In John chapter nine, this unnamed man
gets a whole chapter.
And in that chapter, it's filled with insights, uh,
that apply to each of our, uh, personal lives,
our marriage journey, because this man endures
disappointments and pain, sorrows and grief.
This man experiences the pain of life events.
He was born blind, or we, we would say today stuff happens.
Each of us in our marriage journey is going
to have the pain of life events.
He also has the experience of disappointing, uh,
relationships, even with his own family,
is they're not quite sure how he got healed
or anything about Jesus, not the most, uh,
supportive folks on the planet.
So in life's journey, we're gonna have those life events,
those disappointing relationships.
And even for many of us, a certain irrelevant religion.
The, uh, Jewish leaders don't rejoice with him
after Jesus heals him.
All of us have experienced the pain of
what we might call irrelevant religion, things
that don't really matter, making big deals out of stuff
that's insignificant.
Because in any of those situations,
those painful life events, in any of those situations,
the key question is not a rational why question.
It's a relational question, does God care?
Because the beauty of the John nine story is it says,
after all, the pain of, of the relational disappointments,
the irrelevant religion, the whole issue
of his being born blind, the Bible says they get
so frustrated with him in the, in the Jewish, uh, synagogue,
that they put him out, they excommunicated him, if you will,
from the life of the religious community.
And here's the most important verse
that I want us to focus on in a minute.
It says, when Jesus heard,
When Jesus heard,
does Jesus still hear today about your disappointments,
your pain, your sorrow, your sadness, your rejections?
Of course he does. When Jesus heard it,
He went and found you.
He's not distant from you. He's not ignoring you.
He's not so busy. He can't focus on you.
He's the same yesterday, today, and forever.
Would you bow with me for just a moment?
And we're gonna meditate upon this beautiful passage
of Jesus hearing and coming to find us.
Thank you, father. Thank you, father, that we have a Christ
who knows all things.
Whatever those challenges and struggles in your life are
right now, would you just imagine, however you imagine
and picture Jesus, he hears of them,
embrace the truth of the scriptures.
That when Jesus hears, he comes and finds you.
Would you just imagine now that Christ pursues you
in the midst of knowing you,
and then he wants to reveal himself to you?
Just maybe whisper the prayer of young Samuel speak,
Lord, I'm listening.
What might this pursuing Jesus want to reveal to you
about your circumstances, about your struggle, about your,
so first, listen to his voice
and hear what he wants to say just for you.
And after you've heard from him, respond back
to him in a personal way.
Tell Jesus what's on your heart.
Thank you, father, that we have the privilege
to celebrate your pursuing us.
And we have the wonder that you are a God
who reveals himself in Jesus' name.
Amen.
Now, this will probably start playing,
Get the whole check.
So I'm going to use another one later,
so I don't want to kill that.
Okay. How's this going? Is this all making sense?
What we're talking about, what you're reading about?
Uh, I think I might've said
before that, um, I'm, I've been, uh,
reading these materials that have been produced,
uh, through Dr.
David's Ferguson's ministry for about 30 years now.
And, uh, Uh,
this one just came out about two or three years ago.
And I, and I really think it's probably the best
package of material.
And as you might've even read this week, um,
you'll see these vignettes that are kind of interspersed
through there of this couple named Steve and Barbara Ulman.
They really share vulnerably,
very vulnerably from their lives.
And I always appreciate that
because I just feel like, well, I can trust people
who are being transparent like that.
Uh, I can probably learn from them.
So that's one thing
that we have really appreciated about this.
Um, but we hope that, that you're finding
that, um, you're actually coming
to know your spouse more deeply, even as you go through some
of these times of sharing.
Okay? So I want
to give you this opportunity for just a few minutes
and, uh, uh, I think I'll try to play some music
or something while we're doing this.
But I want you to just practice one thing we
talked about last week.
You may have already done this,
but last week when we started, I had you share something
positive that would've
happened for you during your childhood.
And I focused on hobbies,
and I suggested that you take turns sharing what was a hobby
that brought you joy when you were a kid.
And I mentioned my model building model airplanes
and how that brought me a lot of fun, a lot of joy.
And I'm kind of a nerd
and kind of a by yourself kind of guy.
So I, I like doing those kinds of things by myself,
but also, uh, doing them with, uh, my son is, he got
to be old enough to do that.
But tonight I want you to practice the other half
of Romans 1215.
It's Romans 1215 B.
It's the backside of the rejoice with those rejoice.
It's weep with those who weep or mourn with those who mourn.
Now, I'm not suggesting that you try to process everything
negative that happened in your childhood
or even this past week, but just pick something.
And it's fine if it's from your childhood, honestly.
Uh, a lot of people say, well, why do you do that?
And I say, because if it didn't get healed for you,
then guess what?
It's still in your brain.
And it still could be looking for some healing.
And I think God likes to circle the wagons, come back around
and say, Hey, Bruce, you got one
from when you were about 12.
Let's work on that one. Okay?
And by the way, I've already equipped
Joyce and her heart's ready.
She's gonna help. Okay? That makes it a lot different.
So what I want you to do is just take turns sharing
something, and even just a few sentences of,
here's something that I remember that was kind of sad
for me or hurtful to me.
It could be anything from a pet that, that gets, uh,
too old and you have to put it down or got run over.
It could be your best friend moving away or you moving away.
Uh, it could be something that you really wanted
and counted on and it didn't happen.
Uh, or it could be, uh,
things like parents divorcing
or things like that. But just take turns
Previously shared a little bit about the importance of,
uh, being a 10.
Did I mention that I do not have a good
relationship with technology?
There we go again. So there's probably something
on here I need to kill.
Uh, it was that. Okay, thanks.
Um, whatever, whatever comes
to your mind, just take turns sharing.
I remember a time when,
or a weigh that something happened
and your spouse is gonna be looking
eye, eye to eye with you.
And I encourage spouses, a couple of ground rules here.
Don't ask a lot of questions.
If anything, listen to what they share voluntarily
express care, and then say, is there more?
Is there more? And if they already feel like, no,
I think I've shared what that was about,
and thank you for caring, appreciate that.
And that's really what that verse mourn with those who mourn
really can look like.
Now, it could also look like going to someone's funeral
and spending a lot of time looking at
everything that's about that.
But you know, most of these disappointments in life happen
as we go through life, right?
Mm-Hmm. And I don't know about you that I rarely
have an empty hour with nothing to do.
In fact, I think I was 18 when that was last, the case.
Uh, and we go through them in life.
And, you know, it makes a huge difference when you are
reminded that somebody really does care.
Even if they can't fix it, that's actually what, not
what we're commanded to do.
It doesn't say if one of you is hurting, fix it.
It says, if one of you of you is hurting, hurt with them.
But we're not real good at that.
Normally, that's not what our culture tends to say.
We try to remove people
or rescue them from feeling anything.
So I just had an a sports moment,
and I'm not going to say it.
Okay? It would probably upset half the people in the room.
So, so anyway, we're gonna do that for just a few minutes
and I'll kind of be able to observe
and kind of see when most people are done.
If you're done, just sit back in your
chair and we'll do that.
Okay? So take turns sharing.
I remember a time when, and your spouse is to listen
and offer an expression of compassion.
I'm hurting for you because you went through
that, something like that.
Right?
It just caught me by just
teacher that I had
went back
and recover.
Although there I did better than others.
I had,
I know he hates to see me cry.
Okay? Another minute or two.
You ever heard the song? You ever heard the song?
You say, I am loved? Yeah.
Is that Lauren? Mm-Hmm. Oh, yeah. Yeah.
In fact, I was gonna look for that. And JJ Heller came by.
Yeah, actually, it is what went through my head.
Yeah. That was what was on my mind. Yeah.
So I didn't, anybody there.
Now, some may still be finishing up and that's okay.
I'm not cutting you off,
but I want everybody who is done to notice,
what are you feeling in turn inside right now?
What are you feeling, Gary?
I'm looking right at you, but
don't want to put you on the spot.
No, but I just
Did. I thought that was rhetorical.
So
what she shared is something we actually experienced
together, which was the loss of a pet.
Okay. That, that affected her a lot more than
it affected me,
Uhhuh. And so
I, I kind of feel a little bit my own hurt,
obviously hurt with her.
Okay. Yeah. So it's her.
Okay. It's her, her's, my husband.
But you kind of, even though you were there, you kind
of entered that space with her, if you will, right?
Mm-Hmm. How'd that feel to you?
Yeah. Well, I was, I mean, I had this much of my own hurt,
but I felt her hurt. Yeah.
Because She was tearing up.
And that that also contributes to
You. Yeah. It makes a
difference. Doesn't,
Yeah.
So I'm not to put you on the spot, Terry, but
but how did it feel when he was kind of there with you?
Um, I think about this.
I mean, I probably been on the floor for half an hour
with her because I was just, she was my
constant complain for over 15 years.
Wow. Even when he was deployed, she was
That's right.
He would be gone. Yeah.
That's A family member. Yeah.
So somebody else, what did you feel
after you shared, oh, I'm sorry.
I thought that was my stuff again.
What did you feel after you shared something sad
and your spouse responded to that?
Yeah,
I felt a, a little, a little bit better. Understood.
Okay. Um, Okay.
I think there was an element of what I was sharing
that we hadn't talked about much before.
Mm-Hmm. Um, so it was like, oh, you didn't know that.
Like you knew the story, but maybe not some details. Yeah.
Um, so feeling a little incrementally a little
bit better understood.
Mm-Hmm. And then, so feeling
just a lot of sympathy
and that maybe I don't personally relate to it
still felt a lot of sympathy.
So feeling understood, feeling sympathy.
Um, and then it kind of turned into some like,
hope for action steps
Forward, I guess.
Hmm. Okay. Hopeful. Yeah.
You're, you're picking up on a number of things
that are probably happening in milliseconds.
Thanks, Luke. Anybody else?
Particularly looking for what you felt
after you're spouse
attempted to comfort you with some words that are not,
here's what you need to do,
but here's what I'm feeling for you
About when I shared about
what I'm going through with my dad.
Mm-Hmm. Um, feeling the loss of the years of childhood,
but now he's become, you know, dementia,
but he's nicer and Mm-Hmm.
You know, and it's, we've built this anyway, it's just
a little confusing, um, but able to share
and then her response Mm-Hmm.
Was just great.
You know, you're facing that death of a father and Yeah.
The loss, you know? Mm-Hmm.
So just, uh, her and I just communicating
and encouraging one another through the conversation.
Yeah.
So it sounds like chance that Leah
reflected back accurately Mm-Hmm.
What you were really trying to say. Correct.
Which I would assume that helped you feel heard. Mm-Hmm.
And understood. Yeah.
Um, what about, uh,
the sadness that you might have felt even thinking about
the changes going on in dad,
Ma'am, When she responded to you about that
with her eyes, maybe?
Yeah. Would that leave you feeling?
Uh, just, uh, um, she understands.
Um, she's right there with me Uhhuh.
Okay. And, uh, it's, uh, um,
comfort, I guess,
You know, feel comforted. Yeah.
Yeah. Just, uh, heard.
Yeah. So, and I'm guessing you did not feel alone.
No, no. You know, you can be sitting next to somebody
and if they were trained, like I was trained growing up,
and, and they start responding with lots of facts, logic,
and reason or rationale,
or here's what you might want to know about that
thing that hurts you.
If they start responding that way, even though they
are well intended, you might even feel alone.
Like, I'm not sure you got me. Okay.
Now, I wanted to just take a moment
and process that just with the helps and volunteers here.
Every experience may not be as deep or as powerful,
but what you just experienced in addition to Romans 1215
b, mourn with those who mourn,
you also experienced Matthew five, four,
which is blessed are they who mourn for they shall be what?
Comforted. Now you got
that promise from your Heavenly Father,
and he is described as the Father of compassion,
the God of all comfort.
He not only gets this process, he designed it. Okay?
He's the author of it.
But in that same passage that names him as a father
of compassion, God of all comfort, he's also
assigning us responsibility to give
to others the same comfort we received from him.
I had to learn how to do that at age 45, 19 years
after I married this sweet bride.
She had to wait 19 years for this boy to get it. Okay?
And I hadn't gotten it either.
No, you didn't get it growing up for sure. Right?
And, uh, our testimony includes
that we did not weep together
as Romans 1215 commands us to do.
We had, we did not do that for 19 years in our marriage.
Not because we didn't love each other, but
because we had no clue what that looked like, felt like,
sounded like, why would you want to do that?
And I'm saying, 'cause there's a promise in the scripture.
It says, you'll be blessed if you do.
You'll feel better if you do.
I like the way, Luke, you said incrementally,
I'll take incrementally.
Okay. Sometimes it could be a gusher of comfort,
like a Vietnam vet who had not shared some
of the losses he went through for 30 plus years
with his wife or anybody.
And it all came out at once without
anybody knowing what was coming.
And for him, it was a cathartic release of a whole bunch
of sobbing, tears all at once.
And within seconds after he gathers himself
and takes a deep breath, he says,
I feel like a mountain's been lifted off my back.
And he meant every word of it.
And he's still preaching that. So thanks for doing that.
Also, notice this is about as
unlikely a scenario in which to do that exercise.
You're in here crowded with a whole bunch of people, okay?
And yet, um, I appreciate you making
that effort, okay? But
We'd encouraged to let it be a natural process
that happens daily if you have to.
Mm-Hmm. You may think of that number of things
before you can't think of anything else.
Yeah. Yeah.
There's no limit to how often we might need it
or might have opportunity to give it even to people that
might be serving a set of restaurant.
You know, you just never know.
So, um, so that's
what we focused on last week, was how do you deal with hurt?
And how do you heal, hurt, uh, that has already happened.
That's not about your marriage.
Now, tonight we're gonna shift towards, okay,
how do we now heal the hurt
that comes about in the marriage?
And yet that's a stu that's a foundation block for doing
what we're going to do tonight.
Now, we're not gonna share this one in the room, okay?
I'm not that foolish. Okay?
I was just about to remember I had something I needed to
help anybody else there
would've been a would come healthy.
Yeah. I'm just glad I'm sitting on this side.
Not in the way of the door. No, absolutely.
We, but what we do want to do is to
really help you understand the process that can make this
very constructive and beneficial, bring you healing, okay?
Um, You know,
conflict's inevitable, period.
But whenever you got two different minds,
you're almost certainly gonna have
some conflicts show up anytime.
You don't even want to go to the same restaurant.
I mean, that's conflict.
It just hopefully is on a low level.
And the pain that will inevitably come about
includes hurt, may also include anger or fear, et cetera.
The question is not do we hurt each other?
It's if when we do, what do we do with it?
What do we do with it? Does it just kind
of get swept under a rug as we did really well for 19 years?
Or do we have a way to actually address it
where it doesn't feel like we just stepped
on another landmine?
Okay? So that's what we're gonna talk about.
What do we want to do about it?
So I'm gonna show you one other video tonight.
This is, uh, the Fergusons
sharing another clip out of their story.
You have a, uh, you have an audio on that other tab,
You scared, but you arms strong.
We're gonna make,
Thank you.
Praise the Lord. The importance
of, uh, being attentive
and sensitive to the ways in which our partner has already
been hurt in order that we not be a part
of reinjuring them in those very same ways.
We ended up in one of those, uh, on an occasion
where we're about to have a family gathering.
And, um, Theresa's an awesome cook.
And, um, I had this silly idea that I think I'm gonna help.
So I'll just let her take it from there.
David says, I have an extra gift called whip and drive.
And when I've got things to do,
especially people coming over to eat,
and I'm gonna cook, I am in my whip
and drive mode, which means I'm not very sensitive.
Those people around me because of my whip
and drive, uh, mode.
Well, and David trying to help, he's never cooked before.
And he decided that he had seen other men barbecue.
And what they did was make the barbecue sauce.
Well, he came in and started mixing up this already
prepared barbecue sauce.
And Ms. Woodman Drive said,
what do you think you're doing about?
And just about that tone, at which point he looked at me,
he threw his fort down, turned around,
and walked out of the kitchen.
Now, at that moment, I knew what I had done to my husband.
This is called intimacy.
Really knowing the person that you're married to
and knowing that pain that they may still have inside
of them, I knew at
that point there wasn't anything in the world for me
to do except go in the living room, sit down next to David
and tell him how deeply I knew that I'd just hurt him.
And to confess to him
and tell him I'm so deeply saddened that I've hurt you.
The level that I hurt you.
His father was a practicing alcoholic.
And when he would go out
and try to help Mr. Ferguson work on the car, instead
of Mr. Ferguson being kind and patient
and teaching him, he would curse at him if
he gave him the wrong tool.
If David gave the wrong tool to him, he would curse at him
and send him in the house.
Well, that's exactly the way David felt
whenever I said in that tone,
what do you think you're doing?
It's like I tore off a scar
or a wound that my husband had deeply within him,
and that was my job then to help heal that wound
that I just opened up. Mm-Hmm.
You know, and the, the blessing of that experience,
even the midst of the pain of it, uh,
is reflected in the simplicity of the Bible passage.
There is a blessing with those who mourn,
when they shall be comforted.
So even in the midst of the pain
and hurt, uh, Theresa's sharing of compassion
and comfort was an enormous blessing.
And that set us on a course of practicing
that Bible verse over and over and over,
because it's not gonna be very long until
It's not a one time thing. It's
Not a one time thing. It's
not gonna be a long time before one
or the other of us we're gonna be disappointed
or hurt by all kinds of things, uh, in our daily lives
or in our relationships or friendships.
And so we've learned that the practice
of comforting one another is one of the best ways
to keep our marriage intimacy close.
Mm.
Okay. So
he mentioned his dad was a practicing alcoholic,
or she mentioned that he was also a marine drill instructor.
Bad combination. Okay.
So a key hindrance when we
seek to heal things
that just naturally happen in our relationships,
everybody experiences this.
Joyce and I don't have to go more in about 48 hours
before we got a new illustration.
We can use how to do it wrong. Okay?
But, um, here's what often, uh,
we find the most natural tendency that we have
when dealing with behavior
and someone else, like our spouse behavior
that's either hurtful to us, annoys us, it's difficult,
or we're just arguing over who, who knows what's right.
The biggest obstacle is we focus in the wrong direction.
We focus on our spouse's behavior.
And that might not be too bad, as long
as they are filled with grace in that moment.
They've got plenty of emotional bandwidth.
They're not stressed out.
In fact, they just got back from a trip
to the spa or something like that.
You know, they're just in great shape
and they say, Hey,
I didn't know you were having a problem with that.
Tell me what you need. But that's not normally what happens,
is it, it's usually somebody's accusing
and somebody's defendant.
And then those roles might switch the next day. Okay?
And the problem that we want to help you be aware of
is it's natural to do that, but it's not very productive.
Okay? In fact, a good God
Decided to help me with that.
At that 19 year point in our marriage, he,
he's basically bringing to mind a passage in Matthew, uh,
seven verses one through five.
It says, do not judge so that you will not be judged.
Ooh, that's pretty useful and wise right there, isn't it?
For in the way you judge you will be judged,
and by your standard of measure, it will be measured to you.
Why do you look at the spec?
It's in your brother's slash spouse's eye,
but do not notice the log that is in your eye.
Or how can you say to your brother,
let me take the speck outta your eye.
And look, the log is in your own, your own eye.
You hypocrite Bruce.
First, take the log outta your own eye,
and then you can see clearly
to take the speck outta your brother's eye.
Notice what he said there at the end.
It's not, you can never address
the speck in your spouse's eye.
It doesn't say that it leaves the door open that you can,
it just says what first Remove the login, your Honor.
So what he is saying to me is, first of all, Bruce,
let's put our focus here instead of here.
Now, that doesn't mean, again,
something she's doing is bothering me.
It's just saying, let's first have a look over here
and see if there's anything here that might need addressing.
And then if you do that, then you will be in better position
to be able to help me help her.
It is on the job description of the Holy Spirit
to convict us of sin.
It is not on my job description. Does that make sense?
So I was oftentimes getting in the way of the Holy Spirit
and distracting Joyce from
what the Lord might be telling her.
Does that make sense? So we're gonna practice that.
Now, in your material this week, it was leading you through
and towards doing this.
And, uh, some of you may have already had a marriage staff
meeting where you actually process some
of these hurts with each other.
And I commend you. If you did, it probably won't be
the last time you need to do it.
Okay? It's gonna be an ongoing process, okay?
But we're basically saying that I'm going to
make a list for myself
of ways I hurt Joyce.
And then I will also make a list of ways she hurt me.
Because both are important.
And God's not saying I should be stuffing what's over here.
He cares about whatever is hurting me too.
But in order to first look at the speck in my own eye,
we would encourage people to make a list
of whatever God brings to your mind of ways
that you hurt your spouse.
And when we first did this, we were about 45 years old,
had been married 19 years,
and we had a lot of catching up to do.
'cause we'd never done anything like that before.
The best we ever did was we'd say, okay, I'm sorry.
I won't do that again. I,
and I might have even really truly sincerely meant it,
but that didn't heal the hurt that was already in her heart.
That was a promise for the future.
And the, I'm sorry, didn't come close to communicating
my understanding of how she might be feeling.
Okay? That's critically important. Yes.
So the comment of David
and Barbara where she said he, he was just oblivious.
Yeah. Yeah. How do you, how do you address that?
How do you In the, the extent was Yeah.
In the book it was very good.
I mean, obviously the Lord brought it to mind for David
as to here he is getting upset with his wife.
She's making those trips back and forth. Yeah.
He's in the car upset because he, she's making him late.
But not once did it occur to him
to get out of the car to help her.
Yeah. Yeah. And I'm sitting there going, oh Lord,
Yeah, My husband is awesome, but he's oblivious
Most, most the time. Joyce
might join you in that description. Uh, hopefully. I
Guess what I'm trying to share is you made a comment there
that says to make those lists.
But if you're oblivious to that, those lists exist. Okay?
How can you make the list? Rosa, you are helping me.
You just set the table for me real well there. And
Rosa, That may not be the thing I'm oblivious about,
but I'm oblivious about a lot of
Other things you see? Yes,
Exactly. Exactly.
So there is a reality
that says somebody's not oblivious
and they're not even limited to our human brain capacity.
And that's God himself.
The Holy Spirit knows every single time
and way that I've hurt Joyce.
And then secondly, how I may have been oblivious to it or,
or not realized it,
or distracted by all kinds of other things.
So what we recommend people do is you pray
before you make this list.
Now that sounds like a good Christian thing to do, right?
But pray, believing that the Holy Spirit wants
to answer your prayer.
If you're saying, how have I hurt my spouse?
Wouldn't it be consistent with a good God who wants
to bring about healing and reconciliation and peace
and harmony and all those things?
I'm not saying that just flippantly, oh, just pray.
Just pray. No, I'm saying I need to tap in
and be listening because his still small voice did exactly
what I needed to get less oblivious.
Does that make sense? I didn't say not oblivious.
I said less right? I pray.
We were actually at a, at a retreat
and they gave us the evening to do this exercise.
And so we actually were just following the guidelines like
you'll have in something I hand out to you.
And we just walk through that by ourselves first praying
and saying, Lord, you promised me, if I confess my sins,
you'll forgive me.
You will forgive me. You promised me. So what are my sins?
What have I done? How have I hurt her?
And within one second of praying that prayer, I
remembered something I'd forgotten for 19 years.
And I'm gonna actually share what it was, regardless of what
that might cause you to think about me.
But I'm gonna share what that was as an illustration.
It fits into what we're doing.
I prayed, help me remember ways that I've hurt.
Joyce had my pen and yellow pad there.
And I actually have this thought come to my mind.
How about the time when you told her you
had changed your mind?
We'd been married 19 years.
What do you think I was changing my mind about?
Anybody want to hazard to guess on that one? The marriage.
Married the marriage.
Does anybody remember how quickly we got married?
Oh, Two months, four months.
That means I proposed about a month into the
dating she accepts.
And about a week and a half later, I go back to her
and say, Joyce, I've changed my mind.
And what do you think that left her feeling?
Somebody guess out loud, rejected. What else were we saying?
Inadequate. Inadequate. Well, that was me.
What did she feel? And she could have felt inadequate alone
because you were alone and
Abandoned. Abandoned
with her. And
That she didn't matter. Oh, the dad.
That she didn't matter. The Dad,
I'm sorry. Was it your
dad that Yes. The same thing.
That Good catch. Good catch. That was, it
Was the, it was the kind of thing where it was like, okay,
I'm used to this, this is happened to me
before I can stand on my feet.
Mm-Hmm. I'll deal with it. Yeah.
Yeah. So that's a good catch.
But even if she had never been abandoned by anybody else,
she might have felt abandoned that day.
And as far as she knew, she would never see my face again.
'cause I was on her doorstep telling her I've changed my
mind and I did not feel good
standing on that doorstep.
I mean, I, I know better.
I know better make promises and break 'em. Mm-Hmm.
I wasn't a believer at the time,
but I know that I had a value
of you're not supposed to break promises.
And I was doing that right there to make sense.
Can I I have one little mm-Hmm.
Eight And the B So the B on that is, and I,
and please nobody take advantage of this.
Mm-Hmm. I'm asking is this a Venus and Mars thing?
I'm just asking a little
Great question. The
reason being is I hear a lot
of my girlfriend saying the same thing,
that their husbands are oblivious.
Yeah. I thought, oh, I thought it was just not. Yeah.
I'm asking is it a Venus Mars thing,
Really? No,
it's not. It's not. It's not.
And, uh, in case you don't, haven't heard of the book
or read the book Venus
and Mars by a guy named John Gray, um,
he was pointing out
and emphasizing a lot the differences between men and women.
There are definite differences physiologically as well
as mentally, et cetera.
There are differences and there are things
that men are a bit more prone to do
and women are a bit more prone to do.
But that one's not one of them. Oh, okay. Okay.
Um, women are probably more global in their thinking, and
therefore they're tap tapping into their emotionality.
But I wouldn't say men are less emotional.
It's women have more connections between the brain.
That's one thing he brings out.
But no, this is more about, am I even
asking God to help me better care for my spouse?
Am I even asking that question?
Because he, uh,
knows and he cares.
And he's put his neck out there on the table
and said, you know, get in a yolk with me
and I'll help you learn.
So we would simply say, if you follow the process
that we're laying out here, which is very biblical,
if you follow the process, you might bump into some kind
of obstacle even as you're trying to do it.
But chances are it's gonna help.
And there is a, there is a fallback just in case.
Let's say that I make this list and I make this list.
It's too long, long.
That's my help mate right there.
What am I supposed to do with this list?
The ways I heard her, I'm supposed to confess it,
which literally means to say the same as,
so if I'm confessing that first thing, I, I broke a promise.
I re nicked on my proposal.
If I'm confessing it, I'm agreeing
with God that that was wrong.
Whether she was hurt or not, it's still wrong. Okay?
So I'm confessing to God and he promises he'll forgive me
and he doesn't, Rene on his promises.
And, uh, so I'm confessing that
and the verse that I just referenced about his promises.
First John one, nine.
But then I'm gonna bring that confession to her.
But that's what I'm supposed to do
with everything on this list.
I'm supposed to agree with God, confess it,
and then care for the hurt, hurt
with those who hurt.
It's just, I waited 19 years to bring it up.
She was not nagging me about it. She wasn't bringing it up.
I don't think she really wanted to talk about it.
'cause it would just stir up pain in
her remembering that, right?
But once I bring it up, she doesn't have
to drag it outta me For once.
I'm not being oblivious for once.
I am taking initiative to care.
When I bring that up, she is
vulnerable and she, she's listening
to everything I'm saying at that point.
Does that make sense? Mm-Hmm.
So part of what this, uh, handout's gonna do is
to give you sort of a, um, template for,
what do I need to say?
How do I need to present that to her?
So what it's going to boil down to is
I want to name something to her that's specific.
I remember the time when I told you I changed my mind
about getting married.
That's specific. If I just go there
and say, I am sure I've messed up
being oblivious way too long.
I'm sure I have not been the best husband in the world,
God's probably mad at me and I sure hope you can forgive me.
That's not gonna go over very well, is you. See that?
That's way vague, number one.
And it's not really owning anything, okay?
When I say specifically, I remember
something we have not talked about one time in 19 years.
Got our attention. Okay?
Second thing, call it wrong,
with no ifs, ands, or buts.
Big period right there.
What, what I might be tempted to say is,
but you know, I was so stressed out.
I had just come back from overseas.
I didn't even have my feet on ground, did not have a job.
I mean, I got lots of excuses here, right?
But what if I bring those up right after I say
Neg? I think I heard
you. That would just dilute whatever
good was about to happen.
Make sense? And yet again, our flesh,
once it is like Adam
and Eve in the Garden of Eden, they're saying, you know,
we didn't really mean to, you know, all kinds
of excuses we're hiding, got fig leaves. Now
It was her fault.
It was a woman, right? That you gave me. Blame God.
Yeah, that'll preach. But, uh, call it wrong.
No ifs, ands or buts, including, um,
we'd highly discourage you from saying I didn't mean to.
Hopefully you didn't mean to.
Hopefully it was not malicious. Whatever you did.
But that too sounds like an excuse.
So you're better off just saying it was
wrong of me to do that.
Period. Third thing
may be the most important empathize.
When I asked you, what do you think that made her feel?
And, and a bunch of words were thrown out there.
Everybody who was thinking
or speaking words right then was empathizing.
Mm-Hmm. You're trying to imagine what
that would make this person feel.
Even though you've never been, you know, in her brain.
It's just saying, based on what I know
and my experiences, I'm guessing
that would leave her feeling abandoned.
That might leave her feeling rejected.
That might leave her fitting less than not enough.
See, those are guesses.
That's exactly what we can do to try to understand
and then let them correct us if we don't get it right.
The word that the Lord gave me
or brought to my mind as I was preparing to share
with Joyce, my confession was crushed.
I think it crushed you.
Now, do y'all remember she beat my socks off in tennis?
She not easily crushed. Okay?
She is strong, enduring, persevering, determined.
If you talk about my daddy, I'm not,
Yeah, that would be a different
topic entirely, wouldn't it?
And there I had done the same thing her dad
did in a different way.
And it only took me a matter of weeks.
It took him 16 years to leave the family.
Are we starting to see connections?
Everything doesn't have a connection
to the past, but a lot of stuff does.
So empathizing. Sounded like Joyce.
I think that crushed you.
Fourth thing, express care
as part of the confession.
I've already named it. I've owned it.
I've described what I think it did to her
with flexibility in case she wanted to say, yeah, it, it,
I was feeling crushed and it was also making me,
and then she might describe some more
and I'd say, let her share that
the best thing you can do is care
for every word she says or he says.
That's empathy. And then expressing, care cares.
I am now Joyce feeling what for you?
Sad compassion sorrow.
Be careful to not go down the trail of saying,
I'm now feeling like a jerk.
I'm feeling so bad about,
I don't know why you married me in the first place.
I mean, I'm just lousy at that stuff.
What's the problem with the words I just said?
They're all selfish. They're all selfish. Or self-centered.
Self-centered. Okay?
And it takes the focus off of her heart
and puts it over here on mine.
And sometimes the person
who should be receiving care is actually
saying, oh, you're okay.
I would've married you anyway.
You know, they're rescuing you from your own shame.
You know what I'm saying? Bad timing.
So we definitely don't want to take it there.
If we're the one confessing something, we don't want
to distract it, make it about us.
It's all about, I did something.
I'm now realizing better than ever what that did to you.
I'm telling you what I think it did.
Please tell me more if there is more.
And I'm gonna sit here
and have compassion for everything I hear.
And the other thing that I would tell you
that I was not known
for is I was weeping the whole time.
Going? I was just gonna say, I've
never had anyone cry for
Me. Yeah.
And I could not have made myself cry.
That came freely. It doesn't always happen.
But I trust my sincerity.
Even if I don't have tears from eyes, as long
as I know in my heart I'm being genuine, I'm being sincere.
I'm caring for you, then that'll go,
that'll, that'll be enough.
But to have tears come to my eyes was just a testimony of,
Ooh, we have not been here before.
Does that make sense? So express care
and five is ask for forgiveness.
At the time we were taught this material,
I had been through a lot of Christian training,
biblical training and counselor training.
That was Christian. And I had never heard anybody describe
confession with those two things.
Empathy and compassion.
It was all about own it and make yourself accountable.
Those two things are important. They're not sufficient.
That is not what heals the heart.
The heart, the hurt that's left behind is only healed
through morning and comforting.
And the more we see that, the more we'll trust that
that's God's process.
Use it, use it, use it.
Plus there's a, there's a big part of the confession,
the one John one, nine.
Because if you truly believe you, he's taken that
to the Lord and being forgiven.
He can say, talk to me out of gratitude.
Talk. I'm sorry, say that he talked to
Me out of gratitude. Yeah.
Yeah. Because I have experienced a fresh touch
of God's grace when I pray to him.
And I, you know, if, if I'm getting, if
what I'm hearing is condemnation, it isn't coming from God.
'cause there is no condemnation for those
who are, who are in Christ Jesus.
I'm just gonna start these around that way. And over here.
Have a question. Yes.
Um, what's the difference between e
and express care The same to me.
Is it, is that important?
Sorry. My, my hearing
Aid. The difference
between empathize and express care.
Okay. They seem the
Same. Yeah.
Uh, empathy is you trying to understand
what they're feeling.
Okay. Expressing care is you telling them
what you're feeling for them.
This is you trying to understand.
I think when that happened, that crushed you.
I think that probably made you think
of your dad leaving her.
I think maybe you had thoughts
that maybe I'll never get married.
That's actually one thing Joyce said.
Maybe I'll never find somebody else that'll
be loving me.
She actually, that was a thought more than a feeling,
but it was very important thought.
Right? Does that help? Yeah.
So you're really trying, this one's about you trying
to understand and convey
what you think they failed.
I guarantee you that if that,
even if you're not right on track,
if you're anywhere in the ballpark,
that's providing something very needed
for the person who got hurt.
And when we got through to the end, uh,
I would've been shocked if Joyce wouldn't have forgiven me.
'cause I knew her heart and I knew her faith
faithfulness to the Lord.
And that she knows the verse that says, forgive one another
as God in Christ forgave you.
She believes and trusts all that.
So I wasn't surprised that she would forgive me.
And I felt certain also she won't use this as an opportunity
to just drag me over the coals.
Okay. Her job actually is to forgive.
But here's the first thing she said
that carried so much weight to me.
She actually said in that moment, after we both were crying,
and there's a good cry, there's healing in that.
And when we kind of gather ourselves, she said, you know,
for the first time in my life, a man has come to understand
how deeply I've been hurt.
Mm-Hmm. That's the empathy part of that.
And I used one word question.
The tears probably conveyed even more,
but it's not about,
uh, being long-winded.
That'll actually get in the way. Okay. Trust.
So back to a question raised earlier about what if
there hasn't been a whole lot of this awareness or empathy
or, uh, knowledge of how
things you do has hurt me.
We could say, number one, the Holy Spirit can be counted
upon to want to help with that
and to be trying to help you.
Okay? Um,
and I'd also say, go with what you got.
In other words, whatever comes to mind,
write it down and go with it.
Even if it doesn't turn out to be the biggest thing
that ever happened, or maybe the thing that they would list
I mentioned earlier, uh, when that was brought up,
that there's kind of a safety valve.
And it is this, usually we recommend that.
It's, what I think this homework recommends is take turns so
that one person doesn't get totally drained going
through everything without receiving any care.
Take turns. And so we started with this one.
I usually recommend guys go first.
We started with this one
and you heard the, the impact it had.
And then I would've probably done one or two more,
and then we would've switched off.
She would've shared some, which she did.
And, but let's just say I get down through my list of
whatever it is, seven, 10, or whatever.
A friend of mine had four pages of his confessions
That they'd been married about 20 years.
He'd stored up a bunch.
So when, when I get through all of these, then
I ask Joyce, is there anything I missed?
Okay, that'll, that'll make sure
that you don't leave a stone unturned
that really needs care.
But by then I trust your spouse would be saying,
you're doing so well.
I almost hate to bring it up.
Well, what's the verse about? Forgiving?
A multitude of sins.
A multitude of sins. It's
called, I can't think where it is. Love.
Love Covers. Love covers a multitude of sins.
And you got me stumped also, I don't know the reference for
that, but that's in there.
Okay. I'm not gonna bring up, go to Bible gateway. Okay.
So let me, uh, lemme just, uh,
see if we've got other questions.
First of all, at this point, I want
to talk about forgiveness for a few moments.
But any other questions about the confession part of this?
Both of you have your list. Yes.
Um, it seems like, you know, empathizing number three kind
of opens up a dialogue.
So are you, you know, when you're trying to,
to understand your wife, you're, you're asking her to share
how she felt in the moment,
and then you're responding to how she
is expressing her emotions
Issues. Great comment. Leah.
Let me take a
stab at responding to that.
And then you keep going with more if you want.
Will you highly recommend that you don't?
Like I say, I remember the time when I told you I changed my
mind about getting married.
That was wrong with me to do that. I think it crushed you.
So we, we'd say, don't, don't ask them what they felt
until you have said what you think they felt.
Because that'll carry so much value to your spouse
when they know you are already getting it
when you hadn't before.
So do try to say, I'm not sure,
but I think maybe it left you feeling crushed,
or I think it left you feeling betrayed.
Then say, is that right?
Or if they just start elaborating a little bit.
Does that make sense? So you don't want to rush past that.
Say, Nope, I got five things I'm going to finish.
No, that's, that's a place where you wanna say,
I think this is how it affected you.
And then give them an opportunity
or pause to tell you Yes,
that's exactly right.
Or I don't think it was crushed, but it,
but you're in the ballpark.
I think it was more. And then that's,
and then you just want to keep responding with, I,
I care about that also.
I'm so sorry. I really, really am hurting for you. Now.
See, I was blind for 19 years,
but what matters now is now
I can't change what happened.
Obviously I went back, proposed again.
She accepted again, we got married.
But that pain had never, never been addressed. Mm-Hmm.
It was buried deep within her.
She wasn't walking around thinking about it.
In fact, it, she did not even have it listed on
this side of her list.
I didn't think God could be that good to me.
So it did carry almost like,
I think God made sure you got that on there.
Okay. Does that help? Okay.
Cameron, I think you were gonna say
Something. Well, I was gonna, I was
gonna ask how do you know,
how do, how do you know to be careful with a subject
that maybe your wife's not ready to talk about yet?
Uh, like the especially painful things. But yeah.
But then I started thinking maybe
that's something that I ask her
Directly. Well, I think that's
probably what I would guide you to do,
is you could even lead into it by saying, this first thing
that came to my mind, or
one of the things that came to my mind.
Uh, I, I don't want to put you in a position
of having to talk about it if you don't.
So when I mentioned it, if you don't really want to me
to focus on that now, go ahead and tell me
and we'll save that for another day.
I'd highly recommend you take that approach rather than just
eliminate it yourself out of fear
or wondering.
Yeah. Yeah. You want to get, just say, I'm ready
whenever you're ready to talk about that.
But if you're bringing this, that's going to,
especially if there's already been some other things talked
about then that, that creates a lot
of safety when you start doing this.
Yeah. And, and it is less about like something like
current, more about just, I remember times in the past
where I've mishandled that
and I've brought up something Mm-Hmm.
And it came off more as me just dumping
Almost like, I want to get this off my chest. Yeah. Yeah.
That's why you take it to God first.
Yeah. Take it to God first
and then also check your own heart out.
You know, who is this for? Who am I bringing this list for?
And it is possible that I could feel guilty,
but what takes over that could be like that is I just,
I just want her to think well of me.
And if I don't, if I don't do this process they told us,
then I'm, you know, that, that might get me in the doghouse.
Now the goal for doing this is not
to secure forgiveness.
It is to bring healing to the pain that was left behind.
Does that make sense? Okay.
Let me cover a couple of things on
forgiveness and then we'll let you go.
Highly commend,
Try to have a time sometime during the next week
where you sit down and do at least two or three things.
You don't have to cover everything the first time.
If you get stuck, feel free.
Pull, pull us aside a, you know,
after class or something like that.
And, and we will give you a tip
or two to try to help you get off, off high center.
But, uh, it's usually kind of scary.
We were kind of scared doing it 'cause we'd never done it
and we didn't know for sure how well will that work.
And it is a process that is biblically defined and
therefore it will work.
But there could be other things that get in the way
that we aren't aware of.
And my parents who are strong Christians,
they had never demonstrated the way you
confessed your faults to somebody.
Yeah. Neither of us got that. Mm-Hmm. Right.
My mom was always right. My dad was wrong.
And for 16 years of your life,
he never said otherwise.
That's right. Yeah. Okay.
Forgiveness, uh, first of all, we're commanded to forgive,
but, uh, if you Offer forgiveness,
but you know in your heart you are still carrying
resentment, then
that is not real forgiveness.
Mm-Hmm. You're trying to check off the box.
You're trying to follow the rule,
but that's not necessarily forgiveness.
Um, what's usually there
in some degree is anger or resentment
or maybe even bitterness, depending upon what it is
and where, how it's, uh, come about.
But God clearly in Ephesians 4 31, 32 says,
forgive one another
as God in Christ forgave you forgive one another
as God in Christ forgave you.
One verse of that Ephesians 4 31
and 32, um,
actually I started in verse 32.
It says, put off anger, wrath
and malice becoming kind, tender hearted,
forgiving one another has God, Christ forgave you.
So see, it's really to talk about, have a heart change.
Now how can you do that?
How can you do that when someone's really treated you badly
and done wrong to you?
Hopefully that's not your spouse.
I just brought to mind, but somebody else.
But how do you do that?
And we'd say, the only reason or way we can do that is
'cause it was done for us.
It's like when God forgave me of being one
of billions who sent his son to die in my place,
when God forgave me, some
of his forgiveness came to me.
And it's like a spiritual commodity
that now I've got to share with others.
But some people have been even misled
by religious leaders
that they should forgive without the hurt tied
to the injury being healed.
And I wouldn't say it's impossible,
but I'd say that makes it really, really hard.
Mm-Hmm. So that's why this healing, confession,
caring confession is much more likely to produce some
of this healing that God's trying to bring about.
But when it comes to forgiveness, um, number one,
it is a command,
but it's commanded in a way that says that your heart needs
to be ready to release the
thing you have against the other person.
You can release it. That is not the same at forgiveness in
that sense is not the same as trust.
It does not say that I have to keep sub, um,
there's a word for it.
Sorry. I don't have to keep subjecting myself
or putting myself at risk such as if
that person's threatening my life
or threatening bodily harm, stuff like that.
No, no, no, no, no. It does not say that.
What it's saying is realize
that forgiving is not natural to our flesh.
We forgive because he forgave, he showed us.
That's what love looks like,
but a benefit to you as it gets your anger out of you.
And it's okay if you have to make boundaries.
Yeah. It's okay.
Yeah. That would be another step with a, in a situation
where it was not really safe.
Okay. So
I've always wondered in that We're running outta time.
So just be aware of that. Right.
Ephesians 4 32 says, be kind
and compassionate to one another, forgiving one another.
So if I've often wondered, do I have to be kind first
and show compassion
before I even have the ability to forgive?
Yeah. That, that would be that heart change. Yeah.
That's in that verse. Okay. Okay.
Forgiveness is a choice, not a feeling.
So that heart change is more
of an attitude towards the other person, not necessarily
that I just really can't wait to forgive you.
It, it may not be a feeling that's driving me,
but I think you'll have more of a peace.
Yeah. I forgive you. Okay.
So that's it for this week. That's a big assignment.
If you have already done it, we'd say way to go
and hopefully this reinforces the theology
and the heart of God underneath it.
Okay. So we look forward to seeing you next week.
I do not have a birthday next week,
so I'm not bringing goodies.
I mean, I'm not bringing, uh,
and by the way, if there are any more, uh,
started calling 'em muffins anymore.
Cupcakes out there and you
or your kids would like them.
Hate them, please. Okay. God bless y'all. Thank. Thank you.
You bet. Our pleasure.